[Music]
national football league
and the union partnering to fund one
million
dollars each and up to five different
pilot research projects
aimed at looking for pain relief
alternatives for the national football
league based on
cannabis cannabinoids marijuana
embracing
the reality that this substance can
finally be used
as as a way to maybe avoid
the toradols of the world right the
narcotics
of the world that can have real
long-term
serious side effects albert
haynesworth's thought that you know his
kidneys
were shot right because of toradol now
there's difference between him believing
that and actually being proven but but
these medications these strong narcotics
have real side effects
that can affect lives down the road the
marijuana
plant and the various things about it
that can help
yeah with pain management hey you know
the nfl had been so hung up on it for so
long
and we've seen a softening of the
league's approach toward players who
test positive for recreational use but
maybe maybe we're inching toward some
reality where the nfl understands that
this is something that can be used to
help their players
get through the grind of of practicing
and playing professional football yeah
no i mean i think it's a positive i mean
again
it feels like the whole country at least
is finally getting there for
for this conversation here that there is
a lot of positive still to be had here
you know and and hey yeah i mean of
course smoking marijuana
it definitely helps with pain management
i mean i've got
back issues i've had it when i smoke
some weed they feel
it feels better it relaxes you know then
maybe i could stretch or realign it get
it in the right way
like yeah players players this would be
a much
welcomed avenue and we're seeing you
know more
marijuana thc products being used for
rehabilitation
muscle relaxation you know cbd oils of
course
i have some friends who go oh it's
awesome it works great other friends
where they say it doesn't work as great
but either way yeah let's continue to
research
i know one thing i know too many
ex-players
whether it be my dad's era or even my
own era who feel like their stomach is
messed up from the years of prescription
drugs within the nfl
you know whether that was taking
something to
mask pain you know before a game or
doing something like that
or then you're on the plane flight and i
know i did this a handful of times
you know i'm on the plane flight home i
sprained my ankle in the game it's
swollen
i got nothing in my stomach
anti-inflammatories boom i'm swallowing
three or four
right and doing stuff like that so
that's where it's another i think
positive here overall for nfl players if
the nfl can
can fight this good fight here and we've
talked before about the problems of
masking pain
that's not good it's not it's dealing
with the pain it's causing the pain to
subside
so that you can continue to function
that's what the nfl should be trying to
do so
they put out a request for proposal
where the idea is to find
companies out there by incentivizing the
process with up to a million dollars
each for five different projects getting
people
to be creative to do the research to
find ways to help the nfl
solve its problem and it's it's smart it
creates kind of a competition
and whoever shows that that they've got
the right idea they get the funding they
do the research and maybe the nfl trips
over something that can be used
to help improve the lives day in and day
out
of the football players who are out
there putting themselves in harm's way
every single day hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports